c'est tous les jours dans les chauffeurs
de taxi les chauffeurs de RATP je
m'embrouille avec tout le monde parce
que ça va tu es énervé parce que on
attend 40 minutes on sera voilà que dans
les transports autrement je suis super
douche super
gentilateurs sinon je suis très
mauvaise chose là c'est le triangle
c'est le triangle de la loose
Castaldi alors moi avant je me battais
beaucoup j'étais comme vous j’étais à
bagarreur
tu as toujours été un bagarreur et
j'étais un bagarre et une fois j'étais
dans un bar donc là on commence à
galerie et il y avait un il y avait il y
avait un gars franchement qui qui paye
pas de mine genre tu veux raconter quand
il a enlevé ses lunettes non j'avais mes
lunettes elle va nous raconter la même
histoire ça fait 15 fois qu'il nous
raconte la même histoire il a pris une
il y avait un petit modèle comme ça et
évidemment j'ai cherché la merde
pourquoi vous êtes embrouillés parce que
à l'époque j'étais comme vous je
cherchais des gens qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé mais rien me revenait pas par
exemple de con je lui ai dit quoi ouais
ou tu es un bouffe comme ça un truc
c'est pas possible mais tu sais pas j'ai
envie de me taper donc je l'ai cherché
il m'a dit il m'a dit je vais être
gentil avec toi il a eu des mocassins
vous savez les mocassins Sebago là
les bateaux là avec toi je vais enlever
le mocassin le temps qu'il enlève le
mocassin le temps juste mais une
fraction de seconde il m'a mis son pied
dans ma gueule
et j'avais les lunettes qui étaient
incrustées dans mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas des gens très dangereux et
depuis je me bats plus après alors après
je me battais quand j'avais non
quand j'avais des gardes du corps
avec tous les animateurs de TF1 ils
savaient que c'est pas non plus voilà
c'était pas des Gilbert alors en ce
moment j'ai de nouveau une mauvaise
gestion de la colère et
ma cible attention prenez garde
ma cible ce sont les trottinettes à
Paris et il y a 15 jours à l'angle de
rue aux sources boulevard Sébastopol
comme d'habitude elle grille le feu et
là je vous jure que j'ai failli en
défoncer un taf le garçon sans
trottinette et c'est ma fille qui m'a
retenu je vous jure qu'est-ce que je
fais moi le feu est vert pour moi rien à
[ __ ] de ce qui arrive je passe je
regarde jamais toi moi je suis à pied
toujours donc je traverse à chaque fois
évidemment le gars arrive et là
qu'est-ce que je fais moi beaucoup
d'épaule pour qu'il se casse la gueule
faut jamais faire ça bah oui mais on a
dit qu'on pouvait dire des choses
évidemment le gars il vole dans le truc
il se casse la gueule de sa trottinette
il descend il était assez balèze et là
et là et là ma fille m'a dit je m'excuse
elle est belle ma fille m'a dit mais
papa un jour tu vas te faire tuer par
quelqu'un qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bah le
gars il s'approche quoi il dit qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait à toi et tout ça j'ai
l'impression que c'était pas
parce que normalement un gars tu fais
tomber en trottinette tu te défonces
ou le mec il était pas balèze du tout
frère le gars il était balais c'était
genre quoi vous pouvez lui demander
c'était qu'un jour sébastopolis
je vais lancer un appel est-ce que vous
êtes embrouillé avec Gilles Verdez il y
a quatre jours
ma fille m'a retenu elle m'a dit c'est
pas lui qui elle est en vérité là c'est
pas toi qui retenir c'est lui
normalement tu fais ton permis
le gars il a vu qu'il y avait ma fille
je pense mais non parce que le gars
faut pas
non non non je rigole pas devant ta
fille je prends ta fille je l'amène je
lui ai acheté plein de cadeaux
s'embrouiller toujours quand il y a de
sa fille
les gens n'en peuvent plus de toi tu le
sais
rien il y a un mec qui m'a brûlé un feu
rouge et moi je passais au vert
tranquille PAF il arrive alors
évidemment j'ai une tendance si vous
voulez insulter facilement au volant
parce que je suis planqué tranquille
sauf que là il s'est arrêté ce con moi
j'insulte nique ta mère et tout ça vas-y
fais-le fais-le alors vas-y je passe
gentil quand même je suis connu en plus
c'est gênant alors il se trouve que le
mec il m'a bloqué ma voiture et il est
descendu je croyais pas qu'il allait
descendre j'aime pas quand il descendent
ma voiture est un peu basse donc il est
très grand et franchement il m'a dit tu
sors de ta bagnole espèce d'enculé de ta
mère voilà et tu es pas fâché alors déjà
il parlait français
et alors je lui ai dit je regrette vous
ayez brûlé le feu rouge je vais quand
même fallu que je lui dise quand même
non mais c'est sérieux j'ai dit je suis
désolé vous avez brûlé le feu rouge mais
genre je me dis maman mettre une horreur
ici de calmer le truc tu vois il était
très très énervé il était très grand et
très costaud
comme tous les mecs de la télé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bagarre
donc du coup je répondais comme je t'ai
très grande intimider les petits comme
ça c'est quoi quoi tu as un problème
Delphine alors moi j'adore j'adore
intervenir dans les bagarres en soirée
en fait donc quand les hommes sont trop
bu et il se bagarre entre eux et alors
du coup moi j'ai des excès de confiance
la nuit et du coup et je rentre dans le
tas j'adore rentrer dans le tas des
bagarres et du coup
tout le monde
Swan elle est complètement super
et c'est vrai que c'est moi j'étais un
garçon
pas j'arrive et tout et au final
j'arrête j'arrive à maîtriser les gens
Marie c'est le mec qui rentre dans un
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu pour dire comment on éteint
un conflit mais qui rentre dans le bar
il y a que des routiers il des bras
comme mes jambes et il y en a ils
s'adresse à audio il sait qui le pitbull
dehors de 60 kg il y a un mec qui se
donne c'est à moi pourquoi qu'est-ce que
tu veux ben le mec dit je crois que mon
chien a tué le vôtre il dit quoi mon
chien tu es mon chien
[Musique]
mais comment ben dit c'est à cause du
mien dit quoi vous savez quoi comme
chien bah dis j'ai un petit bichon
maltais très vite je dis votre bichon
maltais l'a tué mon pitbull il dit oui
je pense qu'il s'est étouffé en avalant
[Applaudissements]
demain soir ne ratez pas la grosse
rigolade inédite avec Jean-Marie
notamment boulevard et une équipe de
foot elle est très très très forte la
grosse rigolade
je pense aussi je pense que c'est c'est
la meilleure tu as pas une autre
histoire toi j'adore
moi j'ai plein d'histoires de bagarre
mais qu'on peut pas raconter là parce
que ça se fait pas c'est c'est il y a
des insultes c'est méchant alors regarde
l'utérus qu'il a dit non mais moi c'est
pas moi je descends pour de vrai et
après c'est pas en couille pour de vrai
donc là avec un chauffeur de bus il y a
pas longtemps à Mantes-la-Jolie un
chauffeur de bus après c'est parti en
sucette et tout et il m'a reconnu
pendant qu'on était en train de se taper
dessus
[Applaudissements]
il me sert il m'écrase contre le
trottoir et moi je klaxonne tu peux pas
attendre que je fasse avant de m'écraser
contre le trottoir il me dit bah tu vas
pas lui dire excuse-moi je suis pas bien
s'il vous plaît
alors s'il te plaît
je veux parler je vais te parler alors
je veux dire ah bah je sais pas tu vas
me parler je descends et je descends et
j'ai même pas le temps de discuter il
ouvre la porte de son mais je croyais
qu'on allait parler un peu même pas il
me pète une droite tout de suite moi je
fais quoi je vous saute dessus on se
bagarre dans les marches du bus comme
des clochards après moi je lui saute
dessus et comme j'ai pris l'ascendant je
commence à le taper une fois deux fois
trois fois après moi je te connais
[Applaudissements]